former New Jersey Republican Governor
Chris Christie
seems to believe that he could beat
failed former president Donald Trump in
a Republican primary
I'm trying to do my Tucker Carlson laugh
and I'm failing not maniacal enough
um this is funny for a number of
different reasons now I want to be
really clear uh Chris Christie is a
better candidate than Trump and Chris
Christie the country would be way better
off with Chris Christie as president
than Donald Trump as president but this
is not what Republicans at this point in
time want and Chris Christie has no shot
at winning the Republican nomination
there's an interesting article in The
Daily Beast Chris Christie believes he
can take down Trump does anyone else
Christy told The Daily Beast I think
we'll lose if Trump's a nominee that's
why I intend to be the nominee this is
very very interesting I am the viable
Trump alternative
said Chris Christie to The Daily Beast
swiveling and promptly ending the
interview to go to work the room at the
Keene Country Club on Friday night
that's in Keene New Hampshire so you
read the article and the framing is
basically that he is going to try to
appeal to anti-trump Republicans without
ostracizing Republicans who do support
Donald Trump
okay but as the article points out what
is the math of this nonsense after
polling no higher than three percent in
any of the surveys of the prospective
2024 field so far and after finishing in
sixth place the last time he went
toe-to-toe with Trump Christy seems to
be trying to answer the question himself
before he officially jumps into the race
which is how could he be the nominee his
heart seems to want him to run but his
head doesn't sound subtle Christy seems
to be leaning toward jumping in posing
and answering questions that bolster his
ability to take down Trump like whether
he could actually be a credible
Messenger to the Maga base listen I I I
want to have one of the things about
when we have these discussions
Nikki Haley has no shot at being the
Republican nominee but I've never once
said she shouldn't run anyone who wants
to run should run it's absolutely anyone
who wants to run against Joe Biden
should run everybody should be running
sure but I'm also going to tell you that
Chris Christie has absolutely no shot he
indeed is not polling ahead of three
percent in any poll in which he appears
in some polls he's either not included
because it's just all seen as very silly
or he's polling zero and just doesn't
show up in the poll for that reason when
he left office in New Jersey he had a 15
approval so he's not even really popular
lowest of any Governor anywhere he's not
even really popular among New Jersey
constituents New Jersey Republicans I
mean it's just it's just nonsense and
you have to of course remember the
completely pathetic way in which he
humiliated himself remember back in 2016
eventually Chris Christie dropped out of
the race the Republican primary race and
endorsed Donald Trump and there was this
I mean if the right loves to talk about
Alpha and beta it's not really the term
those aren't the terms I really use but
if you want to apply that filter there
is it's hard to find a more beta event
than Chris Christie standing behind
Donald Trump after endorsing him and
looking like he had some bad clams on
the Jersey boardwalk just nauseous
looking uh I'll remind you of that one
of the biggest things that everybody is
seeing happening and everybody is the
Republican party has become more Dynamic
it become more diverse we're taken from
the Democrats which we're taken from the
independence we have a lot more people
any of so many places you go to
different places
different places in the Middle East you
look at some of the airports they have
you look at the roadways they have you
look at the transportation systems they
have and the trains they have we're like
a third world country we're hearing some
suggestions including some from a few of
your former aides that some people
inside the Republican National
becoming Monkey Wrench in with your
delegates at the state level trying to
clear you away and maybe even put I
think you know David okay good
all right anyway so listen Chris
Christie would be my choice if you said
to me David sir the next president will
be either Trump or Chris Christie I go
with Chris Christie over Trump a
thousand times in a row New Jersey
Republican former prosecutor uh has some
understanding for decorum and how to
interact with our allies on the
international stage any day but that's
me that it's me a a voter to the left of
Joe Biden who is going to choose Chris
Christie
there is no reason whatsoever to believe
that the Republican party uh or any
significant fraction of it is interested
in Christie over Trump and so I welcome
anyone getting in who wants to get in
Christie's campaign would be a Dead on
Arrival and so is Nikki Haley's by the
way which we're going to talk about a
little bit later in the show make sure
you're subscribed to the YouTube channel
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
we'll be right back
plastic it's everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year here's something super
simple you can do to reduce plastic and
help the planet a little bit our sponsor
hold on bags is the company making
plastic free trash bags and zip seal
kitchen bags they're just as strong and
high quality as the plastic bags you're
used to hold on bags are 100 percent
plant-based and home compostable meaning
they break down in just weeks not
decades their zip seal kitchen bags come
in sandwich or gallon size to fit all of
your needs whether it's carrots or
crayons at home I put all of my food
waste in a hold on trash bag throw it in
the compost pile and when I throw a hold
on trash bag in my dumpster I love
knowing it's not filling our landfills
and oceans with plastic single use
Plastics harm the planet at every Stage
production disposal decomposition join
the growing movement away from
single-use plastic these products are
really great it's so easy to make the
switch go to hold on bags.com
Pacman and you'll get 20 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below